I play basketball but I don't play it as
well as LeBron James just cuz you've
hired a UX UI designer if you don't know
how to judge it fully you might have
chose the wrong one even if you do know
how to judge it this portion is like
with me so I think this is one you need
to get selfish like you'd ask your
question
hiring is guessing firing is know like
you gotta go faster
that's how you get [ __ ] done that's in
figure stuff out this is the television
and the television is the radio so
forties [ __ ] awesome great
let's rock and roll
what can I answer do you want you you
could only go last cuz then I'll skip be
able go around so your choice by race
well I think what I struggle with with
my business so I created a specializing
booking platform specific to you working
of groups looking I think where I got a
little confusing where of the business I
find that because we're a service
business I run into where I kind of
either plateau or it's I can't hire fast
enough for the demand so then I just AM
like kind of a sitting duck and trying
to chase hired more artists which
becomes like management so what so on
that as somebody who scaled a service
business is it hiring or is it retaining
its hiring and are you making subjective
calls when you hire how are you the one
hiring yeah right so that's so the way I
ask the question is the most important
part I think most people struggle with
hiring because they come from angle of
fear and when they look at hiring
they're thinking about what they're
trying to protect against because you
think that person or this person or that
person is representing you in this
environment and you don't want them to
[ __ ] up and however you deem it you're
coming from fear the reason I think I've
been able to scale to businesses so
quickly in my life is I'm the reverse I
always think that if my intent is good
that by hiring quickly I can actually
scale and that in the occasional 20% of
time when it's really actually [ __ ] up
my ability to fix it out of intent and
effort is actually greater than me
judging upfront and not hiring at all
so in my fear what that is is that my
table client is a bribe yep for a large
corporate okay and so like reputation
wise they could get much shot but you
don't without your client you're not
gonna see another bride again most
likely anyway right and you would lose
her word of mouth and her word of mouth
is only so impactful but what you lose
for is you're not doing and scaling out
of the fear that maybe it goes poorly
what most people struggle with in
business is they spend all their time on
what's gonna go wrong instead of what's
gonna go right so yeah big clients and
Brides I get it
good news Brides don't have great LTV
right and good news seven out of ten
times it's gonna be perfectly fine yeah
and good news you've hired people that
[ __ ] up anyway so where I'm going with
all this is you need to hire quicker
yeah and be more optimistic versus
pessimistic I think I get worried where
it's the management of both sides and so
like I built my own booking platform to
help management and then what I found is
that many other similar business models
that are like across the country are
struggling with the same pain point with
not having the right manager system
where I was able to build that but my
question was do I hit it a little stage
and become a stem what become a SAS
business which is fine you could do you
want - well that's what you need to
figure out but I will tell you that on
the other side of your business service
business it's been the clearest thing
for me it was my hypothesis going in
it's my natural state people spend all
their time on defense what if coral
[ __ ] up this wedding instead of not
thinking that which then leads you to
hiring Carl instead of not hiring them
because he answered one question in a
way that maybe you as a human
subjectively thought would lead to a
vulnerability well it's usually
it's just like the Claudia yeah but
you're making that subjective call right
what you might think is good may or may
not I mean you've had plenty of brides
tell you this is [ __ ] when you thought
it was great and vice versa right I mean
it's a super important part of this
question like you may decide that I'm
not qualified enough but you're making a
judgment for the market without knowing
the reason you're not hiring fast enough
is because of you your subjective call
let's talk it through well what would be
the alternative to that when you say not
always give me another scenario that's
not that you employed them that's you
every mistake James and Nick do make is
my fault so if you're taking yourself
out of the equation then you're
empowering people who are saying no
instead of yes which is still on you
it's how I see it if you're telling me
the question that you are most worried
about which makes a ton of sense to me
because you're on it because it is the
number one issue for service businesses
is not hiring that's you that's either
you a limit whether you're in the
equation or not it's still you because
you're the one that hired the people
that are making them like I can't just
of course not but by then first
understanding what ideological framework
that decision is being made on once you
let go of the fact that you're making a
subjective call and so are your managers
and that they're not right they're
making a subjective call then it becomes
easier to say yes more than no I think
of it it's like tie goes to the runner
once you change this perspective on this
conversation you'll start saying yes a
lot of times when you would have said no
in the past and then that becomes
defunded
door lock hmm yeah well I think that
there's times that I have said yes that
I will just don't know and then what we
did as we created like like a supporting
League level and then the leave a top
leave level so we would bring them in
like we would probably say no but
instead we've said yes and put them on
the supporting role as opposed to like
the one that actually handled the the
director applying the main language of
the bride but maybe like have them on
the team yeah exactly and then as we
could push them up so that allowed me to
so why not say yes more often now there
so we're started we are starting to that
because I did change my strategy cuz I
didn't I didn't uh share faster because
that was that was hurting mm-hmm um I
think for me just being I guess
entrepreneurial in my mind I get caught
up as well is like well how much can I
actually scale this when there's not
like I could at what point do you say
not a matter of like not trying to be
the man but like it creates additional
problems in other areas because then I
don't have enough people to manage the
the concierge part of it
and according so like as that grows with
then we're creating more problems is it
smart to just like take what you're
doing that's working really well and
there may be pivot in other areas well I
think it becomes a question of how much
margin do you want to make because one
could often in those scenarios be able
to afford it except most people have an
ideology of how much margin they want in
this given year instead of investing it
into the biz yeah yeah so that's you
know that's a personal preference of
what you need to take home are you
caught up in the ideology of what a SAS
business is worth versus a business
growing really well have you had a view
taken on some have you converted your
product and says something that somebody
else can use not officially yet I'm
deciding whether it's even in the energy
that you're bringing to the table I
think it would be worth the risk of
putting the money in to make it so that
you can at least taste what to other
people using the platform as a Cesc you
need the context to know you have 15
years to know the good and the bad of
serve
right you know you can do it service
missus sucks right like push more into
it you you probably need to my intuition
is if you can afford it I would
definitely build out the capabilities of
the SAS product to get a couple clients
just to have the reference point if you
like it better yeah otherwise it's an
unknown right just making front-facing
and adding the variables tends to only
be twenty percent of the equation the
biggest thing was when I was going to
like master master classes lived on that
hair side and I was meeting other people
just like me that are running their
businesses in Miami and they're doing
150 wedding because I like how the hell
did you get to 700 and then I showed
that my platform and they're just like
that's what piqued my interest just for
them to see that and realize that
there's really not something like that
in the market and that's how I was able
to get to where I'm at
it's like it's keeping other people that
I by my perspective is that you should
run them in parallel and build them both
until you have a data point on the SAS
business and then decide if that's what
you want to do started it get on 16 out
of his garage 17 times just to prove the
concept to see if there was a market
there for months until you see that it
was got a warehouse very thin employee
situation so he's making decent money
because he didn't really have to pay too
many people
grossed about 300 or so every year 2018
his biggest year which is 327 he saw
enough of me to take me serious enough
to take my offer to join the company
obviously not coming at any money
to bring some value and you know raise
the company up which I'm proud to say
that we didn't do that 2019 which was my
four year we did it to three last year
and so for me the reason I'm coming here
is we were able to do that with
literally just my mother if you will
going the truck stops going the rest
areas just really well out there right
well reviews we have over 600 five-star
reviews which on the East Coast I look
tired shot wise that is a record right
so on the flip side I don't understand
anything really about the social media
landscape except for the fact that it's
a huge opportunity for distribution I
get that part which is why I'm here
I'm senior team it's been great earlier
today with a lot a lot of stuff that
we've learned so far and so for me
obviously the personal branding workshop
that we had you know obviously I feel
like there's a lot of value there they
you know a company like mines good kid
tagging off what Mary Dale said earlier
like in the truck tire space I wanted to
do black people that I know of like
nationally the end of it we're a
national provider of measurement so I
mean it's a lot of things that we've
been able to garner in the year that I
you know had with him and obviously he's
happy about it I'm super stoked think
very bit of doing together most
important right and so for me I just
want to so can I break it down for you
yeah on the first hot take the
everything I just heard and an honestly
living a very similar life at some level
with a father-son dynamic a couple
things you need to wrap your head around
number one let there be no confusion the
far majority of what is happening in
this room and what we preach here is
about branding not selling and that's
very tough because when you think about
Google five star what's so great about
that is it's transactional and that's
tangible in the short term and a lot of
what we're gonna talk about and a lot of
what we're built on which is really
ironic because in Monica and I talk
we're in this what's called the lower
funnel the digital world not the TV
world yet the juxtaposition that I've
created and debate and completely
believed to be true is that brand is
actually built in here not on TV
commercials and so
challenging for an entrepreneur is every
piece of it like it's gonna take you two
and a half years just to start feeling
true impact on personal brand arbitrage
that you felt immediately from five-star
reviews on Google which then makes
nobody want to do it because I thought
that I don't want to do that I [ __ ]
will keep doing Google search Adwords
because it's transactions and I'm like
cool you can do that I'll see you in
seven years and so right off top I think
if you can run those in parallel which
is take what you learn here and realize
okay that's my like that's what I'm
investing in and let me keep finding
ways to transact on what I naturally
have in my natural DNA I think that's a
very important framework because I think
the reason most you know it's so funny
from a personal brand standpoint more
than from a vaynermedia standpoint and I
think most of you know this I probably
say the word patience more than any
other word and nobody wants to hear me
and that's because I build brand and so
make sure if nothing else and I'll I'll
let you ask another question but like
brand is what we're talking about here
and brand takes time how old are you 26
what you the parties before and you yeah
so for me like we've started to now like
customers new by eight times or more we
give them mud flaps a because they have
to pay for B it's our image on there and
our brand statement and all that good
stuff and see if they don't have them
then of course they get a fire from TLT
so like things like that right like so
we're all in on the brand plate for it
because I do foresee us being able to
continue to gobble up market share which
again like I said we don't spend any
money on anything because I don't want
to do anything which I have sometimes
I'm going to understand nothing right
Facebook Ads all of that stuff sounds
great
what you're doing to some degree I just
feel like it would be counterproductive
for me so I what's fun about it unlike
traditional media which is what I grew
up in is it doesn't cost a lot to learn
you know when I had to run a TV local
spot or $40,000 full-page ad in New York
Times there was no learning you wrote
the check and you [ __ ] ran the ad and
you [ __ ] were like holding your
breath you know Facebook you can run
seven hundred dollars worth ads and
learn [ __ ] yeah so I
you're in control your spending bottom
up you're not paying an upfront or a Vig
that's good for the media company so I
would I would tell you just even feeling
you out quickly you should do everything
you should just do it in 100 dollar
increments you understand you should
know everything at this young of an age
in this kind of level of natural talent
and curiosity and that even brought you
here you should run ads on every
platform just a hundred bucks at a time
that's the beauty of the digital
landscape you don't need to waste money
and the learning scale what I learned at
eight what I'm learning right now and
tick tock running ads against my brand
is what I'm gonna bring to Monica as a
conversation and the troops of my $8,000
spending a month are gonna play out if
that brand spends eight million because
it's a marketplace which is powerful so
I would definitely tell you to do that
and then for everybody the creative is
the variable the math of like buying an
ad is super you can you're gonna learn
that awfully quick it's the psychology
of what pictures and videos you put in
there against who you target to make
them consider you that's the whole game
right so from a systemization standpoint
processes like we have it like really
super document I've like even on the
train so and we have that stuff down to
the point where on board or our
employees all that sounds much easier
now and it's much more efficient and so
from a scaling perspective because we
aren't working more physical retail
location store what right yes just one
I've thought about very much so a third
the idea of friendship of course so
because margins are there I feel like
there's a lot of financial implications
that are in place that I feel like it
can be sustainable without me or us
taking the risk not really the risk by
taking all of that financial burden of
continuing to open up shop at the
shoutout the shop it's one of the great
business models of the last half century
but you have a lot of in my opinion you
even just listening to you you'd
probably gonna want to do some more work
of establishing the brand because it's
too early the first person that takes it
that isn't good becomes a vulnerability
you're gonna no matter how many rules
you put in place you're not in control
completely yeah okay but as a business
model it's one of the greatest models
that the capitalism world has ever seen
you got a brother good to see you again
number one you know I was listened to
you know I was listening and building
like you know name brand which has taken
me 10 years and I you know in the
beginning was a lot of like physical
work and everything and now in the last
few years I've learned through like
Google Ads and an Instagram I actually
was doing new year she's talking about
just you know I really pay attention to
what my clients like with different you
know with different events or trends
that are happening and you know I put
money to us those hats so you know now
number one things you yeah and just like
watching a lot of people actually like
you know I should never I really learned
by watching and listening to people you
know so I'm not a big reader it's hard
for me to read a lot so I said like
listen up or just watch things that I
invented working and trying to emulate
them and see how I can make them better
so now I'm at a point where and gfs I'm
gonna make it a big brand we know this
corporate events private business in New
York but also now we have cross
marketing which is a marketing company
that produces a lot of activations and
like new trends so we could you know
going from order new brand is well wanna
you know my my thing is like how do we
take crush and you know use geo events
to you know build cross
get up you know catch up to geo invest
because there's 2 different companies
that they will go with in each other
execution of about awareness there
you'll buy the output it's your kind of
like asking like hey I've only built up
my upper body now I want to put muscle
on my legs well good news you have put
on some muscle on your upper body which
allows you to probably in some of your
leg exercises be able to hold heavier
dumbbells but until you [ __ ] do the
leg exercises it's not going to happen
most people do it doesn't have the
optics but it's a very important point
obviously with a intriguing kind of
analogy by just you know what people
struggle to understand is once you
establish a new brand you don't you gets
like whether it's empathy or the Sasha
like you're gonna get some level of
siphoning from what you've done in the
past you may not like it I don't like it
you're always gonna get some halo but
even the biggest companies in the world
Gatorades coming out with a new drink
right now right that they have to build
up because they want to be more than
just and guess what
they got a [ __ ] spend and execute and
like establishing a new brand as a new
brand will there be will there'll be
people some like wait a minute I know
that guy like he did a good job of
course you've built a reputation but a
reputation is different than a brand so
you gonna have to build it for five
years and I really need you know some
guidance of how to you know make it grow
I mean I guess have you run Amazon ads
that have you run Amazon ads ah no we
had somebody that works on it but you
know it's the company does okay it's
just like you know there anymore are you
it's the product what products they
selling just t-shirts for now but I
actually want to get out of I mean we I
joked into it a friend of a friend
basically invited me as like you know
listening
and only more stores I want to give him
to the store I'll see you said all these
businesses let's to Willis 5050 and I'll
show the motto how to do with t-shirts
and they do like over a million dollars
and teachers and they have nine six
seven stores the problem came when they
noticed that I have all this other
companies and I could also hold for swag
with teachers I don't have events then
they kind of stopped showing me the
model of how they get to this point so
at this point I really need direction of
how to get a person to somebody did you
just help me bro that store you know I
had it for five years at North Valley
well you know eventually somebody
mentioned earlier one of the speakers
that eventually in like five six years
you know almost everyone's gonna have a
store that's the model didn't women have
a store so you know I had it for so long
and I feel like it's just stuck there
you know everything about this
conversation feels wrong because I feel
like you're doing it out of a
philosophical place of like I've had it
so it I should not waste the fact that I
like you know what I mean like if the
angle of this conversation feels like I
I almost without knowing anything want
you to shut it down because I feel like
you're doing it philosophically not
because you give a [ __ ] the difference
is if you're trying to build a business
just cuz you've had it for a while and
the thought of it going to zero when you
feel like you've put something into it
so thus you should becomes a major
energy loss against you putting that
energy to something else the second you
said a friend of a friend I'm like this
like I was already not pumped and
they're like a friend of a friend I was
like [ __ ] me I think you know like if
you were telling me that you were gonna
build a brand and your deep dream was to
build off-white or Puma or something of
that nature then I got excited a
transactional store of like t-shirts on
Amazon even and I've had the luxury of
sitting down with you a little bit prior
to this like I think that's a big
[ __ ] waste of time it's just like
they say just like loss of losing is fun
in the micro you don't wanna go
completely out of business but like
cutting something that's bringing you
very little in return because of the
philosophy of like I don't want to take
this micro L
or or I've already put in this but what
like people don't see the opportunity
cost issue yeah thank you and from being
mainly it's you you need to monetize
your voice like for you for you no
matter what your no matter what you're
about to say you should you should quit
working with him and start a voice
business and be out yeah bruh for you
that's that I feel like taking my
clothes off already
for me it's mainly putting myself out
there and impostors social media to
musical Beach I'm kind of a private
person you know so at the same time you
know I love about the industry ever any
al of product that we know we put out
clients love us we have a great
reputation but for me well you don't
have to put out anything you don't want
to I'm literally the most public private
person on earth you know by not posting
my kids nobody knows anything about my
private life hmm just work this thought
that like it's in control is laughable
Facebook didn't make you vote for Trump
the Russians don't control you you are
100% in control of what you put out
people are full of [ __ ] right people
want to post pictures of their babies
and their pets and their lives because
they want likes but good news crumb
you're in control
yeah that this be not worrying about
what others think or
at that foundation you know I think
that's where there's me getting older
that you guys already have help you know
hearing everybody even you saying what
you said made me feel comfortable
relatable yeah this is a judgment game
it's a judgement game it's all upside
it's a blank machine it's it's it's just
an exposure of our inner truth and
that's powerful because the reality is
once you realize I always use the
example of like when you had a zit in
junior high or high school like you were
like [ __ ] like you didn't want to go to
school like you like it was the worst
and there was just like nobody gave a
[ __ ] cuz everybody was worried about
theirs it you know it's once you get to
that basic of a level with it it can get
really good people people's biggest
issue is that they over value the
compliment which makes them vulnerable
to getting [ __ ] on the reason I've been
able to cruise is in my comments on
every post literally and back-to-back
comments there's a goat emoji and
there's a this guy took daddy's money
he's full of [ __ ] back-to-back and when
you don't hear either that's when you
win come on
got anything
yet retro actively kind of makes sense I
was an amusing industry before signed a
record deal then I became a music
producer had some moderate success
exited went back to business school then
started working on beer and then served
rose to the top within that space and
I'm sure that through the line um I
built a story that's filled with failure
but I am comfortable with that and in
recent in this last year I've now
started to get like some coverage on my
story a lot of like women are like okay
for I'm the first female vice president
fun and all these things so I'm starting
to see this this moment or this calling
where I feel like I want to share my
story a bit more when I go I'm certain
to get asked to speak at a lot of events
now to where it's a little bit bigger
than just marketing but it's like my
point of view on on life so I'm kind of
at that inflection point where I'm like
figuring out if I should be doing that
or not and then and then and then you're
also in a big company which you know you
have to be thoughtful about how that
works
um I think you should be doing that you
can always work in a company and then
knowing enough about your career you're
in such a great spot there - all you
have to do is just be very thoughtful
and over communicative and what's really
cool it's kind of how I see you know
it's it's fun I mean we're not just
looking at Nick and Maribel and James
they're they're doing things that lets
them tell their stories I'm a unique
dude and how I structure and I
understand that I'm not a bi or 3G or
you know but but I think finding the
right balance of how to do it like
everybody has their confines no matter
what you know Mike I'm even as an
entrepreneur with no board my confines
are the market you know the market
controls my outcome so but I think even
like here's the actual real answer
just for your great-granddaughter to
consume that one day because of the way
the internet actually works that is an
actual win to the answer when I started
really getting aggressive with my stuff
it was absolute
from the standpoint of holy [ __ ]
everybody in this room is actually the
matriarch and patriarch of their family
because we will disproportionately have
so much more content pictures and videos
of us than anybody before us and in 300
years we are like kind of actually the
starting point and I was just like [ __ ]
that's really cool and why wild and I
was like [ __ ] it
like I that's super cool like if nothing
else and maybe I'm affected because I
didn't know either my grandfather's and
probably weirdly want to and like other
things it made it very natural for me
like if all else fails it's a nice
family thing right only celebrities have
had the luxury of really really knowing
to some level even not even to the level
that we're at so I think you need to do
as much of it as you possibly can within
the confines of yeah but like over
communicating upfront with the Machine
how many episodes okay yeah what it's
all about like top 50 management
categories list wicked for us anyway the
question is not related to that
so starting wolf is journey like two
years ago and then five ish months ago
figured hey if we could build my
personal brand with negotiations we
could probably do the same for other
executives for people in my position so
we started a ghost writing slash content
company about five months ago and now
we're pivoting slightly and that we're
going to market to enterprise sales
teams to create them into thought
leaders on legion
I understand us to convert sales better
I understand
and so one of the things that we're
struggling with right now is we're
trying to figure out like we're a small
team four people in a we work and we're
trying to figure out I'm trying to
figure out from a leadership perspective
how do i how do i lead that small team
and grow that like how did you do it at
the beginning while still like keeping
professional /to friendly
because they're basically like my family
I made that my family I don't think
there's anything wrong with that you
just have to be willing to give feedback
when somebody's taking advantage of it
instead of the reverse like to me like
kindness and family and like all that
stuff is the strength I'm at my weakest
when I don't give candor when I cuz I
don't want to give negative feedback to
somebody I care about and I'm at my best
when I do I still think it's better than
the alternative
even at my worst it leads to some people
quitting or firing under bad you know I
still think it's better cuz I think 12
years later everyone still likes each
other more than if it was just
professional so I I think it comes down
to your ability to give candor which is
something that I struggled with and
continue to struggle it's easier than it
sounds
I'm literally pretty public about the
thing I'm probably worst at was that and
I and and that's cost me a lot of money
and it's also made people not like me
that I did a lot for but because I
became entitled because I didn't give
them feedback that they weren't as good
as they thought they were and they were
feeding off of my halo I also think it
depends on what you're aiming for
without knowing his story he clearly
didn't have the leverage enough to like
be in the department that he had that it
led to whatever it led to but in your
scenario we're not talking about a
partnership we're talking about
employees and so what happened with me
and that scenario is eventually I
couldn't hold my breath anymore and I
would fire somebody and they would be
stunned and that led to them not liking
me as much as I could have had them
loved me if I just told him a year
earlier that they sucked and we were
gonna try to figure this out and I've
gotten better at it but I'm still not
remarkable at it but that's all it is
I'm net-net it's a strength to have that
good of a thing I think the bigger issue
of what I'm hearing is when you go into
servicing people to do something most
people don't have the personality traits
to actually pull off what you're saying
and they're gonna blame the service not
themselves so what you're going to
really need to do is
- what she needs to do and what we've
done here is you're gonna have to scale
more people which is probably gonna make
you have less margin up front and then
that's right and you start getting - I
think I'm starting to grow a little bit
myself
because I'm starting to really
understand what works for me and I'm
doing a better job communicating it
upfront to the people that I work with
which is like hey I'm not gonna reach
out to you I need you not I'm asking you
I need you to reach out to me on a daily
basis on text so I have context and so I
can respond if I want to and if you are
setting for it Mike employees that's
weird because they don't have
relationships of the CEOs of the
companies that they've come from so they
think they're bothering me three
businesses now here we have two
locations New York and Miami for my
including company rainylin service and
the problem is we are trying to scale
right now we are kind of scaling but and
at the moment they start realizing that
we cannot scale wort and everyone at the
moment right now so basically we spend
like four yep ads then we started
spending and even though of us then we
only see very very small growth which is
basically like not giving us any more
customers mostly we focus on the
subscription-based customers well you're
also investing in a platform that's
losing consumer value
I mean no you know I'm not I'm not
judging I'm telling you why theirs in a
place that's declining in its impact on
the consumer will tend to not return as
much value it's the same thing I do with
Monica every day not her because she's
smart but most of her contemporaries
which is like please stop buying regular
commercials like it's not going to work
another place that is now more properly
priced so the diminishing returns every
single day continue to decline on the
supply of consumption and demand cycles
PR firm to kind of get some kind of like
organic traffic promise that's gonna be
the worst of the three every hop let's
[ __ ] so how many more time what is the
business do and what is the subscription
the home cleaning service I'm talking
about the subscription-based clients
which is which is residential yeah so
you're looking for us to hire you to
clean our homes good and historically
has been good for you yeah and now it's
not as good like everything even good
news that's how every platform in the
history of marketing works one day when
I'm older and have no hair I'll be
making fun of social media that's how it
all works so what else have you done the
biggest it was similar to what I was
saying him the biggest decision you're
gonna have to make in the short term is
you're gonna have to transition to brand
marketing that's smart
versus what you're all your energy is
right now which is transactional
marketing right because it's his intent
based marketing on
I need a house cleaner in Long Island
enter you show up cool
I want to out beat you did it when I was
doing it for wine for five cents a click
good now those same words are eight
bucks not as good less people even going
to search more people deciding to buy
wine because of Instagram and because of
tick-tock and because a YouTube and
because of podcast couple things one not
open yet but it's for all of you I think
one of the really good ad products
that's on the verge of coming out is a
pre-roll live read meaning a human reads
it
Spotify product that's gonna be out at
about three to six months where you'll
be able to like you buy Google Adwords
and Facebook ads put in a script that
you want podcast readers to read and
then you pay for the impressions and
people just read them like podcast
providers makers right negotiation then
just can decide to be a part of this and
when he starts his podcast he goes
Ricky's Donuts now available in like
literally live read old-school 1950s
radio at scale I think that's gonna be
interesting and you can run it in New
York and Miami only I think your
business explodes if you figure out how
to do Facebook marketing mmm-hmm because
Facebook Facebook is the killer app for
45 to 90 year olds which I already like
from a residential standpoint of having
the net worth to be able to afford a
house cleaner instead of not right
instead of doing it your [ __ ] self
and and and when you really understand
Facebook ads and really understand how
to break down New York and Miami into 45
to 50 different segmentations
and then what video or picture to put in
front of them and really get good at it
Facebook will return so much more for
you than then Google AdWords long term
and will build brand equity and creates
word-of-mouth in a way that Google
doesn't Google I type in I need a house
cleaner in Rochester enter its insular
Facebook if you make a really
interesting ad I may share it or I make
tag Maribelle in it it's inherently
word-of-mouth structured
transactional structured which is why
it's so much more powerful gonna you're
gonna pay somebody to to $8,000 a month
to get you into a magazine I'm I'm
telling you that that's a really bad
idea but good news I'm not always right
but there's nothing as much as I hate
regular television commercials
traditional PR makes regular television
commercials seem like a jet Super Bowl
you can you can DM that [ __ ]
second-rate magazine on Instagram
instead of paying somebody eight four
eight six I mean there's nothing that's
more overpriced than predict truly
traditional PR you could do yourself I
just think it's gonna you know in a
listen what's great about me is my first
marketing budget was forty thousand
dollars for the year I come from a small
business place
it's not fun to waste money it's gonna
take you six months to realize you
wasted twenty four thousand dollars yeah
I get it I believe you and I get it and
I'm also trying to make you also paid
money to be here I really don't want you
to waste money on traditional PR like
what you want the Miami Herald to say
something good about you have you why
call
[Music]
so basically we started at the same time
and even it earlier the novena safer
I'm know for sure you know that this is
our biggest competitor but at that
moment you know I would we didn't invest
it a lot it was started as a hobby and
as soon as they started they started as
a real business because they gave up to
your flowers to Kardashians yeah
real roses did last year yeah they tried
to do the special in oils and make them
last year so now basically the industry
that our main competitor they made
industry they think yeah they made it
like real roses that last year and they
even trade my market so the biggest
problem for us during the Valentine's
Day I would say like now is Valentine's
diamond diamond chemos working crazy
hard 24/7 while I'm here but the main
problem arises during the Valentine's
time we can sell our conversion rate is
not that high is like 2% you mean on
landing on your site yeah okay keep
going it's like it's not that good but
like considering the price the average
price price per purchase which is $250
that's that's fine you know when they
are paying like anywhere between one to
two dollars per click we are getting
people from Facebook and Google Ads
you're happy with your CAC and LTV
numbers okay by doing all the season
like last year we spent like closer to
forty to forty thousand dollars you had
Google included programs and it
literally just spend that money we
didn't be perfect only like vodka
whatever and then like I just saw that
it doesn't work at all well maybe your
landing page just
between 80,000 and try different pages
and like their work maybe maybe the
product and the price point didn't match
the leads that you were getting not be
specifically targeted were specific
audience because our audience is like a
Highlands vigils like cos managers Brown
like you were wrong now I believe every
broadcast really
there is definitely wrong because it's
our get forty thousand dollars and you
only got five thousand six or 107 long
know what the main reason is because he
realized the year before that he got the
most of our sales
we got because our we prepare rivers
they were sold out and that's how we got
like thousands of orders okay and then
the next year we invested even more
because he survived it was the
supporters
let's invest more and let some more and
the next year then they'll be advertised
it G our conversion was like zero point
seven during melena thing because they
they still have the services because we
people actually will not write them I
understand and then our problem how we
can make people write from us by
building a brand and by explaining to
people why your product is better or
maybe it's not as it better or is it
worse I would say you know we just have
different type of devices but it's far
yeah but guess what perception is
reality right so if the boxes is part of
the flowers the landing page is part of
the flowers the words you use to get me
there or part of the flowers what you
ship it in is part of the flowers there
could be a lot of things but that's
probably right I mean if you look at
this table right now there's literally
bottles of water that cost three [ __ ]
dollars I've known we buy feed
is that true these are our bottles like
you know like that's the stupidest [ __ ]
of all time we're literally paying like
it's water what I what I think I'm
trying to challenge you to do is look at
the whole equation and realize
everything is part of the customer
experience and you know I don't you know
to me clearly you have not conveyed to
the end consumer that you're valuable
the only time anything's gone well is
when there wasn't an alternative that's
a problem well the Jets have hired
football players for 50 years and they
didn't work what no but I'm using an
important analogy you know but did you
hire the right people you know somebody
the other day said to me Gary you know
but this sounds so much like the agency
we currently are using and I said maybe
I said I play basketball but I don't
play it as well as LeBron James just cuz
you've hired a UX UI designer if you
don't know how to judge it fully you
might have chosen the wrong one even if
you do know how to judge it how many
you've got 10 to 15 people work on UI UX
for your site I'm sorry okay well that's
a problem because I'll tell you why
you're gonna I understand let's talk
when you have two percent conversion
either the things that you're sending to
the site are wrong or what happens when
you get to the site is wrong there's no
magic yeah of course it might be about
branding and product that might be
what's wrong on the site
what's a site
thank you bad you know
mine's gonna be subjective unless
there's something glaring is [ __ ] which
there might be that's why I want to look
at it real quick but I think I think
that what when everybody here has to
realizes sales is very simple it's you
know who you send in and what happens
when they come in it's not super
complicated you know when it's not
working it's one of those two things or
both or the product itself that's the
only you know it is honestly like a few
orders and like you might have set
30,000 people to the site because you
can see it searches they are using and
we also okay so I have received Mina
subfloor and I've never heard of your
brand and last Valentine's Day my
significant other tried to buy me
flowers from Minnesota for they were
sold out so I got it from another brand
not your brand and I just pulled up your
website and just on the surface it
doesn't feel as premium as them and I
just mean that like constructively like
so some of the imagery like to me like
meanness of floor presents themselves in
a way that like it feels like a Cartier
of flowers it feels like a Harry
Winston of flowers and frankly like some
of the imagery and it's like the site
itself as far as like functionality
literally is structured the same way as
theirs but I think it's like some of
like wave you know with the pictures and
then like some of the arrangements
themselves do not feel as premium and
I'm only I can only say that just
because I I bought I was making fun of
Nick that was a bit listen I was like I
got I got the gist of what you were
saying so I moved on to make fun of Nick
thank you that's that's for competitor
right now this they look fine to me it's
subjective like then and I trust it and
I appreciate it and it's a true singular
subjective and then the issue becomes is
if the far majority agree with her
that's why you're losing and and our
women the buyer because I would write
because I would argue that there's a
very high chance that men are the actual
buyer it's because you told them yeah I
totally get it I totally get it like to
your point is the woman the influencer
of the decision maker is the decision
maker not being influenced just a it's
classic yeah did you guys break up that
would've been the best part of the story
all right I'm gonna move on we'll get
back to and Monica gnosis my interest in
making a subjective creative opinion is
zero what I can definitely tell you is
you've got a problem right I never take
one person's opinion as truth but if her
pinyin is shared by 84% of people you've
got a problem
here's what I can definitely tell you if
her feedback and the collective vibe
here is like the imagery is not as good
as the other thing my opinion is to hire
a very expensive photographer and get
higher bless you no no you know how
people think their children are cuter
than everybody you have to be careful
they that's not your opinion because
they're your competitor you need to
fight themselves I mean like some of the
staging so like that like one with the
champagne on it it feels like you're
like trying to be premium but it's not
he's a [ __ ] businessman he's just
trying to sell [ __ ] that's that's the
problem at hand right it's oh it's also
you you own this a hundred percent let's
start with the fact that it has 33
percent of his energy let's just before
we get into all of our opinions I don't
know the other company that's the market
leader my intuition on what I hear is
that's their business
this guy has three businesses probably
with a fourth fifth and sixth in his
head that's already a problem understood
maybe she's not good
do you the story competition yeah like
how maybe I'm not exactly what they did
honestly they actually that's actually
what has been said before they felt a
breath my friend that's the only thing
that exists
there's nothing yeah brother they they
have nothing I'm sure that's fine that's
fine
guys gals let me ask you a question you
said that they created the category like
they were the ones that burped okay yeah
let me help everybody when you're right
about a category you can hire my mom as
your PR agent the press picks up on an
innovation
let's just let's let's be very it's not
like they came out with a sneaker like
when you create a category you are for
ever gonna win the press game when
you're the creator of a category their
success is the best thing that's
happening to you you spending your time
crying about they have more money than
you is gonna do you nothing what I think
you need to do is how much how much
Instagram posts you put out a day for
that brand yes Instagram posts yeah well
you better not go with whatever because
the entire target market for your
product lives on that [ __ ] platform
one a day whatever is why you're losing
six a day knowing exactly what the [ __ ]
you're doing is how you can turn your
business around and on and on and on I'm
gonna move will come back
yep you're in San Diego but your global
yep yep primarily a lot with like
planners and venues because the beauty
side as you know actually knows it's
very personal as that goes and so I
started it because I wanted a more
personalized experience to like my
specific needs getting ready for events
so a lot of it is weddings and just like
special events in general but with that
is that almost every person that I talk
to you whether it's a new planner or
baby or stuff like that is there like
I've never heard of what you're doing
which is wonderful but it's also like
how do you get don't you don't you just
keep going people get very confused
about convincing yeah versus
communicating and moving on the
execution will create the awareness I
mean you're more than welcome to put a
creative and content that speaks to it
but where people really go to caught up
when they innovate is trying to convince
versus create awareness like if I
couldn't tell like when we started
vaynermedia like social media mark like
almost every brand my brother AJ
literally on his laptop created the
Pepsi Twitter account the Campbell's
Facebook account and what we were really
good at cuz it was an 8 and me and now I
speak to it is we would go into a
meeting that I would get inevitably and
sometimes within four minutes I would
wrap it up because I was like okay this
has no [ __ ] shot this is somebody's
taking this meeting as a favor that I
was able to get into but their actual
interest or even knowledge or even
thought is zero so [ __ ] I'll take
back the 45 minutes and go do something
else and people just like convinced that
of their little heart trying to convince
people it's a huge mistake
my feeling is just as long it's kind of
like what I put out in the world like
you just do it every day in perpetuity I
think how you do that is important
though like this is exactly the kind of
thing that you start a podcast around to
create a pillar place that you then
create post production content in all
places but you have a home where
literally the entire show is about the
genre you got it from you that a lot of
times people aren't going to click on an
advertisement for an attorney but you
got to come up with some content for
them to consume so what I did was I
started doing extreme motorcycle trips
and documenting it and people were
coming in we split up a brand you're a
badass with what you're doing on the
motorcycle they sort of think I'm doing
that in court
and I would say 80% even though I am
hitting some homeruns in court a lot of
people just hire me because I'm in the
community they see me I ride and I've
got all these videos lookie yeah I
travel from the end of the world to the
top I mean life-threatening stuff high
torso okay so I started doing that it's
going great
okay I want to hire two people where I
want to be I want to shut down my law
firm I want to perhaps get a desk at
this other law firm right and all I do
is produce go out there make it rain let
them make the money and I know a size of
the lien Chuck so I've got my law firm I
got people working for me but eventually
you know I'm 55 maybe when I'm 65 or 70
maybe do something like that because I
don't plan to retire retirements right
it's not for me but you enjoyed the
content although there Oh
going out due to the bike weeks yeah so
I mean I think the concept of converting
your business into a top of funnel
lead-gen rev-share business that you can
then push to seven different lawyers or
or a hunt you know
as you know content on the internet is
not regional so now all of a sudden
you've got fans and lead-gen throughout
the entire country you probably can
build a substantially bigger business by
creating a lead gen top of the funnel
business by taking a back-end of the
referral across the globe be way happier
or make a lot more money so the way you
do that is similar to what I said to her
you should start the business right now
you should create content that alludes
to it see what comes to you make a biz
dev arrangement with either somebody in
South America for all of South America
or just Brazil for just Brazil and in
essence franchise out your top of the
funnel business and I mean you could
have 50 law firms in all 50 states as
the person that you've made the deal
with to send on because you believe
they're reputable and they know what
they're doing and they have the
territory and yeah of course of course
of course
there's lead-gen Affiliate businesses
have existed for a long time to your
point what hasn't existed is the ability
for a human being to do exactly what
they love to garner trust and then the
cosine that Trust to another place like
you know listen it's really funny in and
this happens a lot with albums and art
like my first book even though I like to
thank you economy more crush it will
forever be the best book I ever wrote
because I laid out this entire truth in
2008 and it's become true people make I
mean go you want to go read Babs star
reviews go read the first 500 reviews of
it on Amazon of crush it
people like [ __ ] this guy this is a
[ __ ] pipe dream you can't make money
on what's YouTube let go read them
they're hilarious yeah man it's it's
there right now you don't the wait for
65 that's right that's right that's
right that's right
because the first time you get a phone
call and say what the [ __ ] you sent me
to Karen and st. Louis
my same with me they're like you send me
to Nick deal he's a [ __ ] idiot like I
get it of course that's the point course
at the point you're more than welcome to
build my dad's business where he put my
[ __ ] cousin and the one guy he trust
behind the [ __ ] register because he
was scared somebody was gonna steal
plague complete defense and then capped
of course that's the point you know why
cuz you can fix it you're gonna build a
SAS product and see how much you like it
and then it might be boring because you
missed the art of it yeah and then you
won't or you will or dabble both there
there is no right there's right for you
[Music]
you had no idea you you had no idea what
the [ __ ] he was doing yeah you should
you know do you do you understand like
well you know how to judge the guy or
the gal that you hired will you be able
to judge the person that's putting out
the content
that's it so I said the right one so the
you you answered it the right way
there's nothing to talk about here and
fire the more educated you are upfront
the more you know that you can do a poll
sticker in an Instagram story the more
likely you'll be able to interview her
or me more MORE
I would I would I would argue that if
you went on a hundred a sprint to create
content and spend media on every
platform from snapchat to Pinterest to
Facebook to YouTube that that would put
you in a disproportionately better spot
to hire someone people trying to hire
people without knowing the craft how the
[ __ ] are you gonna hire somebody like
like I keep telling people I'm like I
been saying something on stage I'd
rather you know how to do this than
balance your checkbook that's how
important it is so I think a hundred
days sprint on downloading them all
because you inevitably you have your
favorites right now or the one or two
you feel most comfortable with get
uncomfortable and both organic and paid
that's where I got it yeah Facebook and
YouTube and very quickly Instagram are
clearly going to be your pocket I mean
YouTube pre-roll based on Google search
that would be really good for your
business my friend
you know based on both your businesses
there's a product where you can run
YouTube videos on a pre-roll before a
video based on what the person was
searching on Google so it's intent-based
right but it's actually brand so
somebody's searching to buy tires in
your area but then go watches a
Baltimore Ravens video and you pop up
and say hey you look at their tires I'm
like look and then everyone's like go be
searching me now you search for tyre
everyone's like the phone's listen
nobody's let me it's so ludicrous the
phone's listening it's not listening you
[ __ ] search for tires you forgot look
like it's like this miraculous like
everyone thinks like [ __ ] it's so
laughable you searched for tires dick
you clicked on a tires picture that's
how they knew they're not [ __ ]
listening to you sucks is not under your
[ __ ] bed do them all for a hundred
days and then started interviewing and
ask tree interesting question I always
say to my team I'm like look we're gonna
lose 90% of time because we only win
with the 10 best percent of people
because we're so much smarter and we're
not gonna sell [ __ ] and that's how
you want to hire you want to get so
knowledgeable especially at your height
of that hundred day sprint that when you
interview us and you're like so what
would you do with Instagram swipe up
then you're gonna get an answer so I
make fun of everybody in my world I sit
in rooms with people that don't do any
of this stuff they talk about reports
and opinions I'm a practitioner be a
practitioner for a hundred days so you
can ask better questions you'll probably
do a better job hiring but don't use
that you know to your point exactly but
like [ __ ] mistake exactly and just make
and just make and just make and just
just a hunt and then you'll be [ __ ]
you're gonna feel better too because
you're thoughtful you've been successful
it's not fun to guess it's a lot more
fun to hire with a little bright so all
you have to do is make and then by the
way you may discover [ __ ] I actually
love this back to like what do you like
you know who the [ __ ] knows what it
leads to what did you market the firm
for you yeah Mick says keep going so
good and bad news you're still a point
of failure but good news
like I like just because it's important
because it's gonna matter in a second
you started marketing but you're still
the point of failure right but the good
news is what's the punchline like people
all the time that I Gary Vayner it's too
much about you like what if you get hit
by a bus I'm like then it shuts down
whereas a good CEO for a public company
when she decides to go
work at another company that company is
actually in trouble so like like the
point of failure conversation of a
single person is actually funny when
corporate friends of mine say that
because I'm like you do understand that
it is far more likely for the CEO of
your company to go and work somewhere
else than it is for me to get hit by a
bus
and by the way if I get hit by a bus I
don't give a [ __ ] about my ad spend
right now is going shows top a funnel I
got it right right a lot of travel I got
two little kids at home so I I started
doing the digital about eight months ago
organic where where no LinkedIn yet I
just started doing good go figure
selfie no [ __ ] no [ __ ] right so I want
to transition from the trade shows
really or when you do the three trade
shows that you still value got a film it
so you get a ton of content Beauty okay
keep going
is there a geofence account is now so I
go there a geofence or capture those
people who went to the conference with
that but I'm not there now right so
that's cool so I can be target then so
cut that down the question is should I
should I be doing something with those
conferences even though I'm not there
like running ads at those because that's
where they congregate but that's where
my client sells concrete basically
there's but they congregate on the
internet 24/7 365 so don't worry about
it like that my competitor speaking and
so I got to put my face in there while I
even though I'm not there just it's just
that's defense don't play defense it's a
really big theme it really matters when
I analyze from afar who's winning and
who's losing its offense defense I don't
know what oh yeah I have no knowledge of
anything like you know I loved when
James joined the organization cuz he's
like
such a career industry guy has so much
institution knowledge that was the
punchline I wanted to extract that but
when he would like he would talk to me
nonchalantly cuz we've been in the
business for a while enough and he'd be
like you know Johnny Magoo from Magoo
I'm like uh-huh like I I don't know
anything like like I would know that
that flour company existed and that's
where it would end like I don't give a
[ __ ] if rick is speaking instead of me
this year I stayed home because the two
kids I'm tired the Crone's thing [ __ ]
me up I don't wanna travel as much I
would start a [ __ ] call-in show and
LinkedIn every day and that's offense
then I hand off right to the service
provider which is my manager you have to
be upfront with the audience now you
allude you allude to them look what I do
with all my peeps like like as they know
like I never say you're getting me right
you're getting big it's been our media
yeah you got us establish that and by
the way it will always happen like I'm
sure I've had three conversations with
Monica through the years where she was
like but Kerry I love you but like we
love you but like I'm sure her bosses
and things that Gary is amazing but you
know after that like look and I like I
love when people like Gary I've had some
pretty contentious conversation so when
people like Gary you listen you like
you're amazing but like the drop off to
you and your team it's a real problem
for us and like [ __ ] to drop up
for me and anybody on earth is a problem
the drop up for me and your CEO is a
problem [ __ ] you this you don't compare
me and my team compared vaynermedia to
[ __ ] your horseshit agency that's
ripping you off so you've got
established that same truth yes you
start you start doing what I do like
look no like I interject all like watch
what I'm doing not what I'm saying
people know there's a d-roc and a James
and I'm Adam L and NIC like yes that's
exactly right
well by the way but by the way like I'm
leaving in a minute so you can give them
all the answers you want so I feel like
I think the thing there is you can bring
her in in however she wants she might be
introverted mean you might have a master
plan here in the ivory tower and she's
like don't put that [ __ ] camera in me
but you can speak of her existence you
speak in team and business talk not I
started off because my sister would go
out and she would go to a place like so
we live in the suburbs so my sister
would go out and one week she would go
to a place and it would be a great time
and then she'd go there the next week
and there was somebody there and so
basically what I was getting from her
like an app about a lot just three like
the ideation phase what I was getting
from her was just like is anybody
actually there yeah no yeah it's really
funny bring this up it was such a fun
early problem that everybody in Silicon
Valley was trying to solve with the
early iPhone because we knew now we had
something on us and to your point that
is like the big one like and like but
the contradiction between what a venue
would want you to know versus you know
there's so many variables but
nonetheless keep going so like I'm like
here's your budget and I literally got
it's as close to saying I got zero out
of a six-figure budget and like that's a
hard pill for me to swallow because it
was my responsibility and I have people
to answer to for that and so now I like
to hit
so we were launching specifically in
Philadelphia and that was like a polygon
that it was allowed within like for
people to operate the app and for me it
was like about creating concentration
and so we sort of extended that now that
we stopped working at that marketing
company and an extended to December so
and the reason we did that is because
when we did our primary you didn't have
the leverage of the users good news I
promise you this if you walk into a
venue and say if I press a button 19,000
people show up they'll listen that's
what I mean you didn't have the leverage
keep going first and responsible we're
going to the suburbs now knowing that
like they're probably going to be
slightly more receptive even to trying
to remember and so pull one of the
problems that like I experienced when I
was going into the venues in
Philadelphia was primarily was about
trust and so they're like okay well your
platforms free how do you make money and
I remember the first handful of times
that I got asked that question it's like
why do you care and then I started
thinking about it like from like had I
started this idea ten years ago you know
if the technology is permitted obviously
like I was in a place where like when I
in my mind they would be like well I'm
doing this and I need to make this much
money in as much amount of time and my
folks would be like an exit strategy is
you know selling or something like that
and like now like just as I've gotten
older like I come from a very different
place of like through me it's just about
right now like building this platform
out to have value and then caring like I
already have ideas about monetization
but like they're so far down the road
for me that when people ask them like
who cares right now do you feel like
their energy came from a place of the
war stories of Groupon and LivingSocial
or business of course well because
people went out of business which was
the funniest part of it all
Groupon and LivingSocial were so
effective people went out of business
because the people were stupid
and made offers they couldn't afford and
somehow the platform got blamed like
I'll never forget like you know I'm a
pretty like beat your be accountable for
your actions
this woman's like crying in Chicago of a
cupcake store she's like Groupon put me
out of business and I'm like I'm it's
like the sweetest old lady and I'm
yelling at the computer and like a TV
screen in my hotel room brushing my
teeth I'm like [ __ ] you put
yourself out of business the [ __ ] are
you what are you talking about of course
we go in there like right now we're so
how do I garner that trust it's it's
it's actually similar to three questions
ago I think you don't have the time or
energy or scale to commence yeah I think
you just try to add have you asked every
single business you know what I mean
like that's where my head goes I here's
how my head goes if I was like the third
sister and like building this ask ask
ask ask ask you know get through a month
of asking everybody then sit down be
like [ __ ] all knows [ __ ] now we have to
either pick another suburb or commence
commence commence but commencing let me
ask you a question so let's play it out
I'm a gourmet food store well you go to
Wine Library and we have gourmet food
because liquor is a little tricky and
I'm like am I like to innovate I'm Gary
I'm gonna like the innovate I'm
interested in doing this what's the
value what's the what's think [ __ ] what
are we asking put your daily special so
like so why are they what are they
scared of it's just an additional thing
I own a salon for 11 years and like you
get asked all these different things you
get confused on what platform to be on
and just becomes one more things have to
put push that content too so to like
fight that argument from them we did
Facebook integration so I can sign up
and now we're realizing like we want to
get away from like Facebook sign ups can
we think with you step back where are
you at with the business so like scratch
I mean I used to work like in a
hospitality industry so I saw a need for
like slow times and that makes sense did
that come from
you want to be the greatest hero of the
hospitality industry or more from like
I'm in a place in my life where I feel
very entrepreneurial and I want to do
something yeah so I think that so I
think so I'll tell you why I'm going
down this series of questions what's
really interesting to me about this is
you're trying to create a two-way
marketplace the businesses that I've
created to a market places like eBay and
uber and Airbnb are the biggest
businesses in the world I don't think
when people go into two-way marketplaces
they realize how almost impossible it is
to pull off so the reason I'm asking the
question is in my knowledge of the last
15 years of knowing that you have a
point oooo oooo oooo oooo 1% chance of
building this company I want to make
sure why are you doing it and if it's I
want to do something because I have
entrepreneurial DNA and I'm in a
position to do something and I want to
scratch that itch it gets to a much
bigger version of close down your
t-shirt company I want to make sure that
you're going ice white oak and I'm like
[ __ ] these are the hardest businesses to
build on Earth's the one that came to
the here with her family yeah yeah okay
so you do that yes what it takes yeah
and that's like the best thing in my
life is ever getting used to like I to
me that less insurance it does accept
what's really cool about what you do for
a living is there's multiple races to
win whereas with a business you're
running one race and if it's a race
where I'm racing against you and you
actually know what you're doing and I
don't it's highly unlikely I'm gonna win
so for you to have the eyes wide open of
oh [ __ ] and maybe you know it but like
for real now for everybody like to
Marketplace's are literally the biggest
companies in our society people of them
launch a month and nobody ever succeeds
because the balance of chicken-and-egg
ad scale oh I'm gonna say one more time
eBay uber like you're talking about
public companies that built you know
it's a I just want to make sure you
realize how insane of a marketplace that
is incentivize it pay small businesses
to do it let me tell you one thing about
small businesses that are busy to your
point you knock on my dad's door and say
hey Sasha I will pay you $2,000 to try
my product because I need because I need
the example to sell to other people you
will get that answer from every one of
them no give them money they like
pictures they like money more hello Sara
at the Cherry Hill in you we're gonna
give you a thousand dollars in cash to
just try our product it it will work if
you're just so itchy to just taste it
I've given you a really good answer
that's gonna save you a fuckload of time
and money by giving them money you will
go for for for of giving somebody a
thousand dollars for Saturday night to
test when you go transparent and you say
I'm only doing this because I need the
example to sell to everybody else around
the country they will understand it will
be transparent and you will close I can
share with my my fans like hey check us
out on this popcorn because we're gonna
post our specials
don't even ask that yeah it'd be nice
but then I'm saying oh you're asking
you're paying me actually to give you
exposure you just need the example but I
would think as a business I
do that I believe because I'd like [ __ ]
her I'm gonna do that and then she's
gonna go in another liquor store and use
my [ __ ] customers that's how I got
you